معنا من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوط هشام
اذا المحافظه الوسطى وخان يونس كان لهما
النصيب الاكبر من القصف الاسرائيلي ما
الجديد في هذا
السياق بالفعل سهام والقصف مازال مستمرا
لا سما على مخيم المغازي بلده الزوايده
وكذلك قريه المصدر التي تقع الى جانب مخيم
المغازي من الجهه الجنوبيه وبالتالي هناك
احزمه ناريه جنها الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه على هذه المناطق الثلاث وتكثف
من غارتها على هذه المناطق الثلاث
بالاضافه الى استمرار القصف المدفعي على
كافه المناطق في المنطقه الوسطى ال لو
بدانا من بلده المصدر او قريه المصدر فهذه
القريه هي قريه صغيره يسكنها ويقطنها جل
من فيها هم من عائله المصدر
وبالتالي هناك حاله كبيره من النزوح في
هذه القريه لا سما في ظل الاستهداف
المباشر لهذه القريه القصف الاسرائيلي لم
يتوقف عليها ولا لحظه واحده احزمه ناريه
تشنها الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه على
هذه القريه ولم ربما هناك الكثير ودمار
كبير في المنازل من جراء هذه الغارات
الاسرائيليه التي تستهدف في جلها منازل
مدنيه فلسطينيه وايضا البنى التحتيه
الشوارع رغم ان هذه الشوارع هي شوارع
بسيطه وايضا القليل من الشوارع هو هي
شوارع مرصوفه ومؤهله لكن القصف الاسرائيلي
مستمر متواصل منذ عده ايام لكنه يشتد صباح
هذا اليوم ايضا مخيم المغازي دمار كبير في
المنازل في مربعات سكنيه مربعات سكنيه
دمرت بالكامل مسحت بالكامل تغيرت معالمها
من جراء هذه الاحزمه الناريه التي تشنها
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه على هذا
المخيم والمناطق المحيطه ايضا القصف
المدفعي مازال مستمرا الاوضاع في مخيم
المغازي خطيره للغايه هناك طائرات كواد
كابتر اسرائيليه تطلق النار على كل من يح
التحرك او حتى كل من يحاول الخروج من
المخيم وحتى المتواجدين في المخيم من يصاب
من يستشهد يبقى على الارض ينزف المصاب ولا
تستطيع سيارات الاسعاف الدخول الى هذا
المخيم لاجلاء المصابين او حتى انتشال
الجثامين